yeah but Will Smith in the rock need to
make a movie together
they never have so know that that was he
amazed to be the biggest movie in
history history and they bow outs Tom
Cruise get him all together Tom Cruise
Will Smith and the Rob you ever
interviewed Tom Cruise
no but only with my brain when I'm in my
sensory deprivation tank he reaches out
to me
does he really makes a mind-meld okay he
puts on his Scientology earbuds and he
astral travel I tell you it's amazing
interview Tom Cruise what's amazing
about it it's it's because you hear so
many different stories you wake up with
your pants off no I didn't no not
nothing at that time Who am I hypnotized
me but he doesn't break eye contact with
you mmm that's what I like no he just
like hey what's up yeah yeah and what
he'll do is that gay nervous
no no no no no no that's what he's doing
nervous or he's just wants you to know
he's he's locked in right like he will
not break eye contact like if you look
over here be like probably makes it
harder for you to ask fucked up
questions know what he does and I tell
all my all my friends when you interview
Tom Cruise he will take ask him a
question he'll try to make it three
minutes long so he doesn't hat you can't
ask him that many so you got to learn
you got to build a relationship with
them so then you can ask him a bunch see
I've interviewed him so many times I'll
walk it I remember one time I walked in
rows like hey Tom I got five minutes so
we're gonna have to answer these
questions so I got to that point but he
he's great in a nice guy did you ever
get to Scientology no never
the heart of the deal you can't ask him
about that well I I heard a part of
Scientology is for you to walk out the
room saying how great they are and I
just did sense I just did it right yeah
so maybe yes it did it's just oh that's
just a philosophy on like how to
influence people right yeah positively
influence people you want those people
really thinking the best of you well
good strategy well everybody was like
Holly's crazy as this is that every time
I interviewed he's great I love I mean I
love Tom Cruise some of my favorite
people are crazy yeah yeah tell me
someone's crazy that doesn't shake me
I'm not like okay well they're crazy my
favorite people are all crazy yeah like
literally crazy my
favorite people so if someone tells me
that someone's crazy I'm like okay what
else you got
it's crazy not scary to me like Will
Smith is awesome he's got to be crazy
Will Smith sure no no no going on - nice
- nice - smart no get out of here see
that is easy no you Scientologist I have
no idea